Narrator: Ever since
people have been lending
money to each other there has been
one fundamental problem.
What happens when someone can't pay back
their debts?
(writing) Can't pay back.
What are you going to do?
Before I really jump into what we do now
in our modern society,
let's get a couple of
the words out of the way
we're going to use a lot.
These are words that you'll hear a lot
in the context of debt or
in the context of loans.
On one side of the transaction
you have the debtor.
This is essentially the person that
borrowed the money.
(writing) Borrowed money.
And because they borrowed the money,
they now owe money, so you can either say
they borrowed the money
or that they owe money.
(writing) They owe the money.
On the other side of the transaction
you have the creditor.
(writing) creditor.
This is the entity or
the person that is owed
the money or they lent
the money to the borrower.
(writing) They lend the money.
They lend the money.
We have our words out of the way,
but let's go back to our
fundamental question.
What happens when the debtor can't pay
the creditor back the
money that they creditor
is apparently due?
If we go back through human history
they've come up with various solutions
to this problem, we can call it.
If you go back to ancient Greece,
(writing) Ancient Greece
they had a very simple solution to it.
The debtor, if the debtor
can't pay back their debts
well then, become a debt
slave to the creditor.
(writing) They became a debt slave.
If the creditor needs some gardening done,
or would like his or her house cleaned
more regularly, the debtor and actually
probably the debtors
family would have then
had to do whatever the
creditor wanted until they
essentially pay back their
debt through their labor.
That's how Greece handled it, if you know
it's kind of shocking to us now,
but that was their solution.
You decided to borrow
money, you can't pay it
anymore, this is what you've got to do.
Now, if we fast forward a little bit
to maybe Medieval Europe, this is even
Charles Dickens' father
was even caught into this
kind of a bind, but until
the early or mid 1800s
in Europe and the United
States you had the notion
of debtors prison.
(writing) Debtors prison.
Frankly, when I describe this to you,
you'll find that it's
even worse in my mind
then being a debt slave.
In debtors prison they
would throw you in jail,
they would throw you ...
they would imprison you,
that's why it's called debtors prison
and you're not coming
out until your family
pays off your debt.
(writing) your family
or maybe your friends,
if you have good friends,
pays off your debt.
(writing) off your debt.
Just thinking about why
this is especially horrible,
at least here you had
your chance to work off
your debt.
Here if your family either,
in my situation right now,
if I get thrown in prison
will my 10-month-old son
be able to pay off my debt?
No, I'm just going to
rot in prison forever
or what if my family doesn't like me
or what if I have no family or friends,
just for ... I might have owed someone the
equivalent of now of
$1,000 and because of that
I could serve a life sentence in prison.
You could imagine the debtors prison
could be quite harsh and, actually,
Charles Dickens' dad
was in debtors prison.
It can kind of tell you
a little bit about why
he writes the type of books that he does.
Anyway, this is the past,
we are now a civilized
society and hopefully we have a better way
of dealing with the
situation when a debtor
owes a creditor money.
That's the topic of this video.
Now what we do is something
called bankruptcy.
Just so you know, the first
versions of bankruptcy
weren't that different
from debtors prison.
They are actually more
to protect the creditor
then to protect the
debtor, but now we have
bankruptcy laws and for
the most part they're
to prevent this type of
craziness or for someone
to spend their entire life on kind of this
wacky debt treadmill.
Let's talk a little bit about bankruptcy.
I'm going to focus on bankruptcy as it is
in the United States.
Let me write down
bankruptcy in a new color.
(writing) Bankruptcy, bankruptcy.
It's going to have a U.S. focus.
In general I'm going to talk about
personal bankruptcy,
although a lot of what
I talk about, on some level,
applies to corporations
as well.
I've actually made videos on that as well.
Let's say I'm just overwhelmed with debt.
I have $100,000 of credit card loans,
I have a mortgage to
pay, I have a car lease
that was a little bit over my head
what can I do?
There's a couple of options
in the United States.
You have Chapter 7, it
seems very complicated,
these are all different,
literally, chapters of the
bankruptcy code.
(writing) You have chapter 7.
This is called a straight bankruptcy.
This is literally you
go ... it's not a simple
procedure, but the gist
of it is you go to the
bankruptcy courts and
you say look I can't pay
back my debts.
What they're going to do
is they're going to take
my assets and then
whatever there is there,
they're going to split
it amongst my creditors
and then after all is said and done,
I don't owe anyone anything,
although I've lost a lot
of my assets.
Some of them are exempt, they let you keep
things that you need to live
like your pots and pans,
and maybe one television,
and maybe a suit so that
you can find a job, but
if I have a bank account,
I probably don't because
I got so deep into debt.
But if I have some money,
if I have a nice diamond
ring or a Rolex watch,
they're going to take that
from me and the trustee,
the bankruptcy court
is going to take that from me, sell it
and then give it to all my creditors,
but at the end of the day
after all is said and done
I'll actually be free of all of my debt.
It's kind of a way to
break from this cycle
of always owing money
and always just barely
making it or probably
not making it at all.
That's a straight bankruptcy.
I say why doesn't everyone
do that who's under
a big heavy load of debt,
well one there's a lot of
rules that make this easy
or not so easy to do,
but the other thing is it
stays on your credit report
for 10 years.
(writing) 10 years on credit report.
So, you've got to think to yourself,
am I going to be better
off over the next 10 years
continuing to pay off my debt?
If I can pay off my debt,
if I have any chance
I should probably do
that so that I don't ruin
my credit for the next 10 years,
but if it's just a hopeless situation
I might as well do it.
Just so you know, this
isn't a cure for everything.
If you've got ... If
you're sitting on $300,000
of student loans, I say,
wow, let me just ...
that's going to take me
more than 10 years to pay
anyway, let me just declare
Chapter 7 bankruptcy,
it will be unfortunate to find out that
student loans cannot be forgiven in
a Chapter 7 bankruptcy.
There's a whole set of types of loans,
or I guess you could say
types of liabilities,
things you owe to other people that
cannot be forgiven;
certain types of taxes,
student loans, child support, those won't
be forgiven.
This will definitely
apply to things maybe like
credit card loans.
This isn't just a very,
very simple process,
so any of these things that I talk about
you definitely want to
consult an expert on your
particular situation to get
a little bit more detail.
This is just an overview.
That's Chapter 7 straight up bankruptcy.
I don't have what it
takes to keep servicing
my debt, I want a brand new start.
Now, the next one, or
the next one you're going
to hear the most about in
the context of a personal
bankruptcy is Chapter 13.
(writing) Chapter 13.
This is often referred
to as a reorganization.
(writing) reorganization.
Here the idea is, look, I have a salary,
I have a job, but I
just have more debt then
is imaginable.
It might not be just because
I've been irresponsible,
maybe a medical emergency
came up in the family
or I had some unknown expenses that just
popped up out of nowhere.
So, here the situation
is, look Mr. Creditors
out there, I really do
want to pay you back,
but what you're asking
for me to do right now
is just crazy.
If you ask me to do that I'm just going to
end up in Chapter 7 eventually,
so for both my sake, me as the debtor,
both for my sake and for your sake,
why don't we come up
with a plan so that I can
realistically, so that I can realistically
pay you over the next 3 to 5 years.
That might involve you saying, hey
instead of being owed
$50,000 you now owe me
$40,000 or instead of
the interest being on my
credit card being 20% a
year, let's change that
to 10% a year, so there
will be a little bit
of a negotiation.
You're going to have
to come up with a plan
and once you come up with that plan,
I've got to pay that over
the next 3 to 5 years.
(writing) 3 to 5 years.
Once again, you might say
hey that's pretty good,
if I owe $100,000 in credit card debt
and I kind of go to my creditors
and look like a genuine individual
and make a nice sob story
they're going to lower
my debt, I'll be better
off then if I didn't do it.
Here again, there's a penalty to doing it
and once again it shows
up on your credit report.
In general, they're going
to come up with a plan
for you to pay back your
creditors over 3 years
and then after that it's
going to show up on your
credit report for another 7 years.
(writing) 7 years on credit,
on your credit report.
So in general from the time you file until
the time it leaves your credit report
it's going to be 10 years,
just like Chapter 7.
In either of these situations
these aren't things
that you want to just jump into
and think, wow, I've found
an easy out from my debt.
These are very serious
things that will impact you
for a reasonable chunk of your life,
so these aren't just simple things to do.
They are good to know
about just in case you do
find yourself a little bit over your head,
or a little bit underwater
or you know someone
who's in this situation,
at least it is an out
where they can feel that,
look, if I do this or that
then maybe over the next
either 3 years or 10 years
depending on how you
view it, they can get to
a new start.
Just so you have a sense
of how often this occurs,
I looked this up a little bit earlier.
In the U.S., in the U.S.,
and as you can imagine
we're in the middle of a recession now,
so bankruptcy filings are
going through the roof,
so let me write this down.
This is Chpater 7.
(writing) Chapter 7 and here's Chapter 13.
If you're wondering what
are all the Chapters
in between, there's a Chapter 12 which is
essentially Chapter 13
for farmers and fishermen,
they get a few more benefits
than the rest of us get,
just because we want to promote,
I guess people who produce food.
Then there is Chapter
11 which is essentially
business reorganization,
it can apply to some
individuals who are essentially big shots,
their personal portfolios of assets
and liabilities look
a lot like a business,
so for them Chapter 11
will be more appropriate
than Chapter 13.
Those are kind of the two other Chapters.
From a personal bankruptcy point of view,
Chapter 7 and Chapter
13 is what most people
concern themselves with.
Now just to give you
the numbers of how often
this is occurring, just
if you find yourself
in this circumstance,
just so you know that
you're not necessarily
alone and also just to see
that they really are increasing right now.
(writing) 2007, 2008, 2009.
Chapter 7 filings in the
United States in 2007,
413,000, in 2008 it went up to 560,000.
This is a more than a 25% increase.
Then in 2009 819,000
filings, essentially double
of the number of Chapter
7 filings in 2007.
If you look at Chapter
13, in 2007 we had 277,000
filings, so for every 2
Chapter 7's there looks like
there's about ... well
for every 4 there's about
3 of these.
Then we have 334,000 in
2008 and then 370,000
in 2009.
You can see that the
Chapter 7 ones are ...
I mean they are both
increasing really fast,
but Chapter 7 is even more dramatic.
You can imagine because
in a situation where
people don't have jobs,
Chapter 13 really isn't
that viable of an option,
they really have to
do something like Chapter 7.
Anyway, hopefully you found that useful
and you know a little
bit about bankruptcy now.